[Music]
abby schudo is tv's perkiest goth a
brilliant scientist and
a shameless caffeine addict we're here
to give you the full story behind
ncis unforgettable forensic scientist
from her trademark pigtails to the
reason her actress departed the show for
good
while abby might be well known for her
cheery disposition
she's also a serious-minded forensics
loving crime solver
this balance feels very natural and it's
no mystery as to why her
actress paulie parrett came to the show
with a degree in criminal justice
she had planned to go into law
enforcement before she got bit by the
acting bug
early roles on shows like the drew carey
show jessie and dawson's creek finally
culminated in 2003 when she landed the
role of abby
abby's first appearance comes in a
two-part story in jag's eighth season
after a body is found near the potomac
river the jag team calls in the
investigative unit at ncis to help them
uncover the truth of this suspicious
death
our introduction to abby is remarkable
to revisit the character debuts nearly
fully formed
while we learn more about her as the
show's many seasons wind on
abby's most distinctive ticks and
trademarks are all on display in her
very first outing but
for a dinner
get me an idea too and i'll make a cafe
atlantico
the first scene featuring abby shows her
calmly watching some guys blast a
mannequin with a shotgun
later when she's detailing some pretty
gruesome x-rays she shares the
particulars of the damage in a detached
almost
board-sounding deadpan that's a
cross-section of what a 12-gauge did to
an l3 to l5
right from the beginning she's unlike
any other character on television
though abby's aesthetic affectations
might lead a viewer to assume she's
gloomy and brooding abby
is actually incredibly upbeat and happy
though she drives an adams family-esque
ford model a
the death investigator is an unusually
bubbly type
he wears three thousand dollar italian
sunglasses and has justin bieber on his
hard drive can't we arrest him for that
perette has said that this perkiness was
very much a choice and
actually modeled after a dog i patterned
everything abby does physically after
this rescue dog that i had named cece
so the way abby stands she stands very
upright and even the way she [ __ ] her
head
everything is done exactly like this dog
abby's energy is all natural too
for the first six years it was hawaiian
punch but then i quit eating and
drinking refined sugar so now i have
unsweetened cranberry juice it tasted
like five
billion percent raw cranberries she
loves extreme music
all black outfits and spooky dolls but
there is one thing she regrets about her
deathly lifestyle
a prominent spiderweb tattoo on her neck
perette doesn't have to reach too deep
to find that feeling in herself
the actress has been open about how much
she hates having the tattoo applied
before filming every day
every day that i come to work i have to
prepare myself for the dreaded putting
on of the neck tattoo
i absolutely hate it perette added that
she tried to get the writers to add a
tattoo removal arc to abby's story but
they wouldn't budge
this is far from the only physical
irritation that perette went through to
play the character
dyeing her hair black once led to a
disastrous allergic reaction
i dyed my hair on wednesday and i went
to work at five in the morning on a
thursday
i would wake up the next morning and my
head was getting bigger and bigger
it would be a real shame if perette was
putting all her actorly effort into a
half-formed character
luckily the writers of ncis have been
able to give abby quite
a full life over 15 seasons abby is the
adopted child of deaf parents therefore
making her proficient in sign language
abby's biological parents are deceased
though the manner in which they passed
is never discussed
born in new orleans the frequent moves
her parents made have given her a wide
breath of knowledge about the southern
united states
her interest in forensics came from one
of the places she lived as a young girl
at one point her family lived next door
to a wrecking yard she found herself
wondering how the cars arriving at the
yard in such a twisted state became so
mangled and eventually learned about the
field of forensics
abby threw herself into her studies
graduating from lsu with full honors and
a bachelor's degree in sociology
criminology and psychology
she then earned her master's from
georgia state in criminology and
forensic science
it is also implied that she got a phd in
chemistry at several points throughout
the series
abby was quickly snatched up by the ncis
team after graduating becoming an
integral part of nearly all their
investigations
abby tends to work alone she has good
reason to be wary of partners though
at one point in the series the ncis team
takes on another forensics expert named
chip sterling
he works as abby's assistant though she
grumbles about the intrusion
the team's senior field agent tony
denozzo jokes about sterling's
relatively minor screw-ups
in time chip launches a plot to frame
tony for murder
apparently holding a grudge against him
from a time before he was on the ncis
team
after this plot is revealed chip tries
to kill abby to avoid being captured
after avoiding her own death abby asks
her director if she can work alone from
that point forward
chip sterling's attack wasn't the last
time someone would make an attempt on
abby schutto's life
a hitman comes after abby in the 15th
season of ncis
her life is only saved by the
intervention of an mi6 agent named
clayton reeves
after tricking the man who wanted her
dead into revealing his identity abby
opts to retire from the ncis
though abby spent 15 seasons with the
team she says her goodbye off-screen
she leaves her bosses a note to let them
know she's gone and heads to the uk
that's where the series claims abby is
to this day
in the real world peret's departure from
the show was a little more complicated
than abby's
abby's goodbye was written as a way
around having to put actor mark harmon
and perette on set at the same time
perette claims that harman
was physically abusive to his co-stars
and that he is the reason
she will never reprise her role on the
series in a revealing social media post
perette made it clear that she's afraid
of harmon
no i am not coming back ever i have
nightmares about it
i have a new show that is safe and happy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
ncis are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]